tuesday edition pft p.m
from the barn and i've moved the camera
angle around a bit so you can see a
different part of the barn it's not like
the barns that big but there's two sides
to it you saw one side last time this
time you see this and i kind of like
this is a very old rocking chair that
used to be at my grandmother's house i
have no idea how old it is i have no
idea how is it how it hasn't shattered
into a million pieces down here at some
point over the last four years but it's
pretty sturdy it's pretty comfortable so
the overarching chair plus whatever you
see in the background a bunch of little
helmets and guitars and whatnot just
another slice of what we have going on
down here in the barn so let's get right
to it what do we have going on in the
national football league i saw that
stephen jones the cowboys ceo was on
radio today with our friends 105 3 the
fan in dallas talking about
the
visual evidence suggesting that dak
prescott had a party on friday night
with up to 30 people present ezekiel
elliott there as well now previously the
cowboys position had been no comment on
anything related to that situation well
stephen jones had a comment today and i
think that's part of the jones dna
frankly even when they have no comment
they still have a comment so stephen
jones had this to say about the evidence
that came out over the weekend about an
alleged reported whatever party at dak's
house we certainly communicated with
jack and zeke and i think they're
certainly aware now of how sensitive
these situations are i don't think
you'll be seeing that
anymore
now there's two ways to take that
either it won't be happening anymore or
if it does happen
we won't be seeing it anymore which
two different things obviously so we'll
we'll see which of those two ends up
applying to zeke or dak or neither uh
that it would just be done and over and
everybody moves forward and nothing more
like this is going to happen everybody
takes seriously the requirement to stay
at home until the requirements stay at
home ends hope hopefully they've learned
a valuable lesson through this and
everything moves forward in the proper
way moving forward for the cowboys
something we mentioned today on the pft
live program
dak prescott not showing up for the
virtual offseason program
it's really not a surprise because he
wasn't going to be there for the real
off season program but the thing is with
everyone cooped up
and with limited opportunities to get
ready now for the 2020 season i thought
maybe there's a chance he approaches it
differently maybe there's a chance that
dak participates in this at home process
because really you're at home what else
are you doing it's better for him to
spend the four hours at home per day
four days per week involved in the
virtual
off-season training program than say
going to a local gym and working out
there with dez bryant
so
regardless of the fact that it would
make sense in many ways for dak prescott
to do that he's not going to do it
without a long-term deal from the
cowboys and we reported that on the air
today and i can reiterate that dak is
not going to take part in the virtual
off-season program to be conducted by
the cowboys unless and until he has that
contract it's not a lot of leverage in
comparison to what it would have been if
dak prescott had been in a position to
actually not go to the facility not take
part in any of the
real practices and workouts that are
going to happen or would have happened
over the next six weeks or so but it's
something and remember the ultimate
deadline here june 5th not june 15. july
15 that's when the cowboys and dak
prescott must have
a multi-year deal in place or he can
only have a one-year contract for 2020
so i don't know whether or not this
stance is going to cause the cowboys to
finally give back what he's looking for
but the bottom line is this as mike
mccarthy gets ready for his first season
coaching the cowboys he's not going to
have dak prescott present or virtually
present for the off-season program
one other thing that i want to touch on
before i answer some of your questions i
posted about this earlier today and on
the surface it kind of surprised me but
the more i think about it it really does
make sense college football season and
i've been
very blunt in my belief that there's no
way that college football can be played
if campuses aren't open to students you
can't perpetuate the ruse of the student
athlete if there's no student and if
it's not sufficiently safe to open up
campus for in-person classes how can it
be safe enough to bring back the
football players and have football
season you just can't do it so there
can't be a student athlete if there's no
student and if you just let them be
athletes and give them an exemption to
come back you admit to the world that
they are just pieces in this gigantic
billion dollar money making machine and
i don't think enough people at enough
schools get on board with admitting that
to allow college football to happen as
anticipated september through
early january however
there's
apparently a possibility for
doing it a different way for working
around the likelihood or strong
possibility or whatever term you want to
apply because right now nobody knows but
in the event that we can't have college
classes in person in the fall
which means you can't have college
football in the fall
chris fowler of espn said earlier today
and these comments came courtesy of
sports business daily that it's being
discussed and it's gaining momentum to
have college football 2020 played
february through may of 2021
and look
i guess i'd be fine with that it would
allow me to actually watch and enjoy
college football season because
currently i travel on saturdays anyway
it would put a real crimp in the nfl
draft because
the college season wouldn't be over by
the time that teams would be getting
ready to select players in april of 2021
they'd have to move the draft back which
i'm sure they would do to give them a
chance to number one let the season end
and then number two have some
effort to scout these players above and
beyond the actual football season itself
but it does create an opportunity for
the nfl too and this is a drum that i've
been banging if there's no college
football in the fall
the nfl if it finds a way to play its
games
can move its broadcast that big cluster
that we have on sunday at 1 pm eastern
and the multiple games we have at 4 25
pm eastern that don't get televised
beyond the local markets you can slide
those to saturday and you can fill three
windows on saturday like they do late in
the season when we get all excited
remember that day in december when it
was the texans and the buccaneers and
the night finished with the bills and
the patriots and for some reason i can't
remember the game that was in between
but that is what you could do
every saturday a triple header on
saturday triple header on sunday
you got thursday night you got monday
night and you also could maybe do friday
night if high school football doesn't
happen the one big thing to remember
here before the nfl could do this the
nfl would have to get clearance from
congress
to
broadcast games on saturdays and fridays
between labor day weekend and early
december because that's part of the
balancing act for the broadcast and i
trust exemption that's the law that
allows the nfl to put its tv rights in
one big ball and sell them to the
networks not have the cowboys sell their
games and the cowboys make a ton of
money for selling their games and then
the teams that no one wants to watch
selling their games and making a hell of
a lot less which is how it would be
without the broadcast and i trust
exemption because these are 32 separate
businesses they couldn't bundle the tv
rights together anyway my point is this
before i put you to sleep with details
about broadcast and i trust exemptions
you can't just start broadcasting games
on saturday even if there's no college
football you need to get congress to say
it's okay but why wouldn't it if college
football abandons that space
for 2020 so then we get more nfl
football and the college football season
would piggyback so spring football
doesn't work if it's college football
maybe spring football works something to
keep an eye on but that's the kind of
creativity that college football is
going to need in order to pull off its
season and i don't know what kind of
creativity the nfl is applying other
than we plan to play and hopefully
they'll have a plan in place for
whatever may happen and however the
virus controls the calendar for the
months of september through january all
right let's answer some of your
questions
pftpm policy did vince mcmahon decide
that he didn't need another year of
losing money to get the tax write off he
called the xfl 2020 now that covert 19
changed the economy i think it was more
complicated than that i think vince
mcmahon was hoping to ultimately make
significant money off of tv rights and
we really don't know how valuable the tv
rights would have been because the
ratings never stabilized and they had
big challenges coming up with college
basketball reaching the climax to its
season april bringing baseball back how
many people really would have watched it
started high and it just went down and
down and at some point it was going to
flatten out we never got a chance to
find out and i think with the very real
possibility they wouldn't be able to
play the games in the spring of 2021 or
maybe mcmahon has caught wind of the
possibility that college football games
will be played in the spring i think he
realized it was time to pull the plug
and chapter 11 bankruptcy different than
chapter seven chapter seven is
liquidation we're going out of business
we're done that's what the aaf did last
year chapter 11
is reorganization which means
you use the bankruptcy laws to
avoid paying your debts while you
reorganize the business and then you
emerge with some sort of a business plan
so if they were totally done if it was
over if they were put it would have been
chapter seven now sometimes the chapter
11 can become a chapter seven and that
possibly will happen here but the fact
that it's chapter 11 tells me that there
is some sort of contemplation by the xfl
to continue and i saw a report yesterday
from daniel kaplan with the athletic
that the xfl is for sale so i don't know
who would buy it right now but if
there's somebody out there that maybe
thinks hey i've got the money i haven't
been dramatically affected by the drop
in the stock market and i'd like to own
a football league that person may be
able to buy the xfl on the cheap and
i look i'm not ready to declare that
there's no place for the xfl and the one
thing and i mentioned this last week
if and when someone embraces the concept
of old school football and finds players
who are willing to assume the risks that
players assumed all the time back in the
80s and the 90s before the game got a
lot safer there could be a market for
that right or wrong and there would be
plenty of people who didn't like it but
there would be a market for that and i
always thought the xfl was going to
pivot in that direction maybe someone
buys the xfl and pivots the xfl that way
in an effort to fill what i think is a
thirst out there in some
uh corners of the country and maybe in
more than we realized for that kind of
football to be broadcast on tv all right
what else do we have here
this one's from the pft pm posse it
relates to a topic we already discussed
but i'm going to go ahead and answer the
question with no off season as of now at
least who has the most best leverage
between dak prescott and the dallas
cowboys i think that
not having in-person off-season workouts
gives the cowboys more leverage for now
they can wait until that july 15
deadline to work out a deal with dak
prescott dak would have had a lot more
leverage to squeeze the cowboys if there
was going to be an on-field traditional
off-season workout program because at
some point they're going to have
football practice not in pads but it's
football practice and if you don't have
your starting quarterback there while
you're trying to get up to speed with a
new head coach
that's a problem and that would have
been a big problem for the cowboys now
look there still may be some sort of on
field off season program on the back end
of the pandemic i doubt it though i
think there won't be any off-season
programs and i think that does help the
cowboys it it it puts less pressure on
them to do the deal
now
that they would do in july and see
here's the problem
if dak uses the occasion of a virtual
off-season program to try to squeeze the
cowboys to do a deal they could move to
a bottom line right now
and that could say that's not good
enough and from the cowboys perspective
it could be their bottom line but if dax
says it's not good enough
the real deadline continues to be july
15 for a multi-year deal so you move to
your bottom line now
and then you're stuck because dax says
no
and there's still another deadline out
there later where dak moves to his
bottom line and maybe squeezes more out
of the cowboys that's the danger that's
the dance and that applies with any
negotiation that's why we always focus
on deadlines real deadlines not fake
deadlines now sometimes a fake deadline
gets treated as a real deadline by both
sides and it can work
but you got to have both sides on the
same page or the other side ends up
squeezing
the side that moves to its bottom line
the worst thing you can do in a
negotiation is move to your bottom line
prematurely because if you do that you
eventually will end up moving beyond
what you thought was your bottom line i
don't know if that counts as any type of
cle credit but you know what you can go
ahead and try you can go ahead and try
and if it works you can
you can cut us a check for uh 0.2 hours
of continuing legal education via the
pftpm podcast all right what else do we
have here
interesting question from pft pm posse
it comes from uh at playoff cap can you
see do you think that tom brady and or
drew brees will retire if the 2020 nfl
season is cancel
first of all it's way too early
to think that the nfl season will be
cancelled i don't think it's too early
to at least factor that possibility into
our assessment of the broader situation
because right now we don't know what's
going to happen and i think if anyone
says they know what's going to happen
they're either dumb or they're lying or
they're both no one knows so i think
it's fair to at least say what if and
that doesn't mean you're rooting for
there to be no season why in the hell
would anyone root for that other than
people who just don't like football and
don't want it to be on tv even then why
would you root for it because what goes
along with it means you know we're still
in a bad spot from the standpoint of the
pandemic and the economy and everything
else we should all want football to be
back because what that means is
we're all doing better than we have been
over the past five or six weeks so with
all that said if there's no football in
2020 i think brady's done no
wait gotta get the right br i think
breeze is done
i think brady ends up still applying
because brady's made it clear he's gonna
play until he's 45. now maybe he
ultimately won't if he wins the super
bowl or something can walk off into the
sunset but if there's no season it went
in the super bowl and walking off into
the sunset he's going to want to play at
least one season with bruce airings in
the tampa bay buccaneers he's not
retiring if there's no football in 2020.
for drew brees different situation all
together because
i think the saints in their mind i
remember when sean payton not long ago
had that that freudian slip or sims
would say for a idiot slip that that
this is drew brees final season they
want to turn the page to taste some hell
and move forward with him interesting
angle to all this
if there's no 2020 season
is taysom hill
still a restricted free agent does
everything get kicked forward by one
year right
and
do the saints
have the ability to keep hell around
with that first round tender of
somewhere between four and five million
dollars or would he become an
unrestricted free agent and the saints
would
risk losing him if they keep drew brees
for one more year that would be a factor
in what the saints want as well all
things considered i think there's no
football in 2020
brees won't play in 2021 but tom brady
will all right what else do we have here
interesting question from pst pm
see what happens is because i follow the
pft pm policy account all the questions
that he posts end up at the top of the
stack of questions but here's one what
teams do you think will be
the best and the worst prepared for this
drought from an i.t communications etc
standpoint and look i mean i can start
making guesses and i could
bring back
just you know our own kind of
half-joking stereotypes about the teams
that are dysfunctional and maybe that is
the rule of thumb maybe dysfunctional
teams do dysfunctional things as big cat
always says and that dysfunction will
manifest itself
in everything a team does including
whether to what extent the team is
prepared for this draft and
maybe that is the right way to look at
it whether it's
how you make best use of the mechanisms
available to gather information and
patriots code bill belichick made it
clear in talking to reporters on monday
that they are using these rules to their
advantage yeah you can't have in-person
visits you can't have private workouts
the pro days were done but you can talk
to an unlimited number of prospects as
often as you want
as long as well no an unlimited number
but you're limited to three times per
week per prospect one hour at a time so
you can call them up to three times a
week as many times as you want as it
relates to all the prospects i really
make that worse instead of better as i
tried to cover my mistake there anyway
all prospects you can talk to three
times per week an hour at a time and it
comes down to how much time you can a
lot to that how much discipline do you
have are you willing to sit there think
about this for a second there are
hundreds of prospects are you willing to
sit there and talk to prospect after
prospect after prospect it gets
exhausting
but
if anybody is going to find a way to
work that to their advantage it's the
patriots because they find a way to work
everything to their advantage and the
flip side would be the dysfunctional
teams maybe don't have the foresight to
figure out how to use that to their
advantage and i think that same mindset
would apply to
the i.t situation you know the teams are
willing to spend the money the teams
that aren't cheap and we know the teams
that are cheap somebody responded to the
question by saying the bengals probably
still have dialogue i wouldn't go that
far but
there are a lot of expenditures that get
made by nfl teams and there are plenty
of owners who are looking for ways to
pinch pennies and this is not an
occasion to pinch pennies if you want to
get the most out of your preparation for
this virtual draft so you need to have
good i.t people you need to have the
best possible internet capability with
backups and redundancies i got the
impression last week talking to brandon
being the bill's gm that
teams will have a hard-wired
backup to the wi-fi you know you never
see that anymore every once in a while
stay in a hotel and there's that old
blue ethernet cord that that
plugs in to your computer and most
computers don't even have that at least
the apple computer doesn't the thing
that the jack for the ethernet cord but
that's the way to do it that's the way
to eliminate any of the problems that
may arise from having the uh the wi-fi
go down during the draft so maybe the
simple answer is dysfunctional teams
will continue to do dysfunctional things
and the best teams will continue to do
things smart and right and appropriately
and they will benefit from whatever the
circumstances may be all right one more
question from pft pm posse before i say
he's had enough
with so much economic uncertainty
especially related to the salary cap in
future years how should teams structure
long-term deals for star players outside
of tying deals to a percentage of the
salary cap well hey you know that's an
interesting point
because
let's say christian mccaffrey
his deal
four new year's 16 million dollars per
year in new money and what that means is
they took the money he was due to make
this year and next year and added in 64
million over four years on top of it it
turned into a six-year deal and we'll
see from the structure how much gets
paid early how much is guaranteed
what his cap number is each year
but
the cap number for 2021
that may end up consuming a
disproportionately large chunk of the
cap if the cap goes down see that's one
of the risks of doing these long-term
deals that's one of the reasons why i'm
glad we do these from time to time
because i hadn't really thought of it
that way i haven't seen the official
christian mccaffrey numbers yet my
understanding is as of last night the
deal wasn't actually done it's just
agreed to
but when we see the real numbers
2021 is going to be important because if
they play this year without fans it's
going to hurt the bottom line
and if they don't make a ton of that
money back by broadcasting gains on
saturday for example there's going to be
a limitation
on the total revenue and the total
revenue this year determines the salary
cap next year if the salary cap drops
significantly
that means if you have a set number for
a certain player that player is going to
consume a greater percentage and look
that's the downside to the approach i've
been advocating for years that a player
should say specifically a quarterback i
want a set percentage of cap every year
i want 18 percent every year whatever
the
crashes then you're screwed but you know
what the teams are really going to be
screwed because they're going to have
contracts that have set cap numbers for
2021.
what do you do then do you have to cut
half your roster and then hope to resign
is there going to be this this huge
influx of free agents and teams are
going to be taking capped charges
because they have to cut guys because
they can't carry their cap number under
the contract they'd rather take the cap
hit that goes along with cutting them
will players be cooperative and
voluntarily reduce their pay for next
year because of reduction in the salary
cap like espn talent is doing you know a
lot of things are going to get turned on
their head next year if the nfl doesn't
make the kind of money this year
that it otherwise would make it a normal
year and without fans i don't know how
you come close to making the money that
you would make in a normal year so
that's an important point and that's
something that that merits discussion
because this christian mccarthy contract
could end up being a huge ball and chain
for the panthers not not that they could
avoid it what are you gonna do he's your
most important player
and i guess they could squat on
the fourth year of his rookie contract
the fifth year option but if the guy
wasn't going to show up this year if the
guy was going to draw a line in the sand
if the guy inevitably was going to say
trade me to a team that will pay me
it wasn't a good outcome for the
panthers either way so that bears
monitoring as we get closer and closer
to whatever the nfl is going to do in
2020 all right
uh
let's move on
oh our good friend leapers 500 has some
non-football questions i may circle back
to those let's not let's not get people
turning off the podcast during the
football portion i may have some
thoughts on some of these non-football
questions that are being posed
libras 500 asks this how much does
anyone know about students ability to
lead the patriots offense well here's
what they know they know what they saw
in practice last year you know what they
saw in the pre-season last year and
the coaching staff in new england
presumably has the skills and abilities
to
watch the film
reflect on the interactions that
happened what kind of demeanor jared
stood have had there's been praise
heaped upon him by defensive players
like stephon gilmour and devin mccourty
there's a lot when you work with a guy
exclusively for a year that happens that
we don't see
yeah he doesn't play in the regular
season he played on a very limited basis
last year they see him in practice they
see him running the scout team they see
him in the meeting room they see how he
interacts with his teammates they see
what kind of swagger he does or doesn't
have so they're in a position to know a
lot about it's much better to go with a
guy who's got one year of experience
than a rookie because the guy who's got
a year of experience
you've experienced him you know what he
can do or at least you're able to
project what you think you can do based
upon everything you've gathered on the
practice field and everywhere else so
look it may not translate because it's a
different situation altogether when it's
time to go out there and play in an
empty stadium with no one there that's
another dynamic too maybe you're more
comfortable with jared stidham knowing
that it is going to be like practice
right it's going to be like a scrimmage
there's going to be anybody there isn't
that going to be weird if that happens
it's both fascinating and depressing to
think of football being played with no
fans i was watching some of the packers
vikings game last night from 2009 and
you'd hear the reaction of the crowd and
they blow the horn in minnesota and
can you imagine watching an nfl game
without that well
we may be we may be watching 256 nfl
games without that and that's going to
be a factor for some guys because some
guys need that in order to get the most
out of their own inherent abilities and
some guys freak out when that happens so
for jared skinner i don't know maybe a
break in season with no fans is just
what the doctor ordered so i think
the patriots know a hell of a lot about
jared stidham and the fact that it's
jared stidman brian murder currently on
the depth chart and tells me they've got
faith in jared stidham whether or not
that faith is justified we'll find out
coming up in september hopefully we
begin to find out in september of 2020
not 2021
and this leads to the next question from
our good friend libras 500 do you
honestly think the nfl season will start
in september i find it very unlikely now
again nobody knows what's going to
happen
with the pandemic because the virus will
determine when it's safe to do things
but i am convinced the nfl is determined
some way somehow to play this year now
maybe they only play 14 games maybe they
only play 12 games maybe they get
started
and understand at some point they're
going to have to stand down if there's a
second wave of an outbreak in november
or december but i think they're going to
play they're not going to give up the tv
money they're not going to give up the
revenue they're not going to put
themselves in a position where they have
to pay the players to not play and i
know that some have reported that the
nfl won't have to pay
if they don't play i'm telling you the
cba the standard player contract says
nothing
about
any type of forced major clause fancy
term for
i don't know what it means but all it
means is you're screwed uh
if if there's a clause like that in the
contract that covers a pandemic because
that gives one side the ability to pull
the plug and not pay you that's not the
contract so
the nfl
based on my reading of the agreements
would still have to pay all the more
reason to make sure they play and all
the more reason for the nfl and the
nflpa to work together to come up with a
solution that everyone is okay with you
know the nflpa could be very obstinate
here and good news is they worked out a
deal to do the offseason program between
the league and the union there may be
some other deals that need to be done
before we get to the point where we know
whether or not we're going to play and
it would be a huge pr debacle if the
nflpa is credibly perceived as being the
ones who delay
or prevent a football season from
happening all that said i think they're
gonna find a way i really do
i i don't know how i don't know where i
don't know whether or not they'll have
to play all the games in florida i mean
florida has determined that football and
other professional sports are essential
functions meaning that even with a
stay-at-home order in place professional
sports can go forward now the nfl is not
going to use that as the impetus for
allowing the jaguars the buccaneers and
the dolphins to do anything because the
league's position is that all teams have
to have the same rules otherwise it's
not fair if one team can't go to the
facility and another team can but
if the stay-at-home orders are still in
place in september and if florida still
regards professional sports as an
essential function
that's a scenario where in theory you
could take all the teams to florida for
four months but look anything like that
that would involve teams that are
quarantined teams staying in a hotel
teams away from everyone else
you're asking a lot
to get these guys to abandon their
families for four or five months the
guys who don't have families they won't
care the guys who do have families kids
wives whatever
at a minimum they're going to want their
families to be with them
um even then they may not want to do it
because they're going to keep their
families safe every day you show up at
the locker room you're running the risk
that
coronavirus is going to be
sweeping the facility and you're going
to bring it home to your family so a lot
of issues a lot of questions a lot of
things to resolve but i think the nfl
will find a way to play its games in
2020 and you know what it ultimately may
be that for some of these players
they choose between playing and getting
paid or not playing and not getting paid
with no consequence like
daily fines for a hold out or any type
of punishment forfeiture signing bonus
they could work out a deal where any
player almost like a conscientious
objector to the draft any player who
conscientiously chooses not to assume
the risk of playing football this year
can choose to not play but i'll tell you
what if they do that
they're still going to have 53 yards per
roster now
it may be more xfl than nfl by the time
it's all said and done but
i don't know is aaron rodgers going to
walk away from 35 million
for four months
of football especially when he can
justify his sacrifice by understanding
that he is helping the country through a
difficult time
i think more guys would play
whatever the requirements whatever the
rules whatever the sacrifice
i don't think you're going to see guys
sacrifice their money and their ability
to play football
if it comes down to it it's kind of the
same mindset that applies to a lockout
or a strike i mean these are different
circumstances altogether but
if a player is given the choice
play and get paid or don't play and
don't get paid and those are two boxes
that players like to check they want to
play and they want to get paid and i
think more of them would go ahead and do
just that all right let's see what else
we have here
nfl leads slash uk if the nfl season
can't go ahead as normal why couldn't it
be delayed until later in the year like
the ncaa is considering the offseason is
so long
there's so much leeway for this to
happen so what you're suggesting is
just like college waiting until february
could the nfl wait until
november december january february to
start the season here's the problem
though at a time when we're so sensitive
to the overall physical toll that
football takes on a player and i didn't
address this earlier as it relates to
college football but
if you delay the season
and the season ends in
may
how do you turn around and start it
again in september
right 16 games
11 12 13 however many for college
you got to give guys time to recover
you got to give guys time to heal what
if somebody tears an acl in may
when are you going to see that guy so
these are very real concerns when you
talk about moving the football season
back because there's another football
season right behind it and and do we get
into a situation where you start 2020 in
february so you start 2021 in january
and 2022 in december and you ease it
back in that way and get back to
september after five years i don't know
i i
i just think that the nfl is going to
find a way
to play the games in september and it
may be very controversial it may not be
popular it may entail players assuming
risk i think they're going to find a way
to play in september without having to
do anything crazy other than maybe
shorten the season
maybe delay it by a few weeks
but they're going to be hellbent to play
those games and catch those checks from
the tv networks
10 newkirk who gets signed first cam
newton or jameis winston
you know this question keeps coming up
and peter king and i think addressed it
last friday on pft live
i really don't know
because for newton the impediment is
having the ability to determine whether
or not he's healthy and if you can
determine he's healthy he gets a job
right away doesn't he
for winston it's not about health for
winston it's about who wants it and it's
also about winston recognizing that he's
no longer a high-end starting caliber
talent in the eyes of the nfl
organizations he's gonna have to come in
and accept a backup role and will a team
even want him to be a backup if he's not
willing to accept being the number two
guy on the depth chart you know every
year there's a handful of teams that
have a backup who really isn't a backup
he's a ryan tannehill type of backup
he's just getting up to speed and if the
starter stumbles the backup takes his
place most teams want a guy who
understands what his role is and doesn't
aspire to upset the apple cart and put
the starter on the bench so
you know jameis winston before he's
going to get a job has to accept he's
going to be a backup and accept that
he's truly going to be a backup because
you know if the bears
which really are the only team out there
that's firing a shot across the bow for
its starter if the bears wanted jameis
they could have gotten him instead of
trading for nick foles now look what the
chargers do jameis winston with tyrod
taylor it sure sounds like the chargers
are going with tyrod taylor i think
jameis is going to have a rough time
here and i think he's got to come to
terms with it it's going to be an
extended process to go through anger
denial bargaining depression and
acceptance and ultimately he's got to
accept the fact that
for now until he gets a chance to prove
himself on the football field prove that
he's not making a bunch of stupid
mistakes and putting himself in position
to have 30 interceptions again that
teams just aren't going to believe in
and remember last week if you watched
pft live and saw this first of all thank
you second of all you've heard this
before and maybe you agree
the 49ers just feel like a good fit for
jameis winston because
kyle shanahan simplifies the offense for
the quarterback
the quarterback doesn't have to make a
lot of decisions on the fly it's very
regimented it's very a leads to b leads
to c leads to d
not go out and figure out
in the moment what the right thing for
you to do may be that's how james
winston gets into trouble when he gets
creative when he feels like the play is
slipping away and he tries to make
something happen
you need to iron that out of your
existence if you want to be successful
in the nfl and one way to do that may be
to play for kyle shanahan so that would
be an intriguing development if it
happens but at this point i don't know
who gets signed first i think it will be
cam newton if we get to a point where he
can go somewhere and have a proper
physical and a team can come to the
conclusion that he's healthy because if
you can give him that physical and
conclude he's healthy why would you not
want it if he's healthy he's one of the
best quarterbacks in football all right
tyler fernes wants to know what do i
think the biggest surprise will be draft
weekend look i
i have no idea because this is so
different than any other draft we've
ever seen is there going to be some big
trade that happens during the draft we
haven't seen a lot of trades in advance
of the draft and i think at this point
you know if there's going to be a
yannick and gawkway trade if anthony
harris is going to be traded by the
vikings some other veteran players going
to be traded i think that they're going
to wait to do it until the picks on the
clock because
the last thing you want to do when you
acquire a pick is acquire it early and
give the teams behind you a chance to
speculate on what you may be looking for
and then leapfrog you and get that guy
before you can do that pick do that
trade when that selection is on the
clock so there may be some trades that
already are tentatively going to happen
that no one knows about you gotta trust
the other people who are part of the
transaction to keep their mouths shut
but it could be that we see and dockway
traded during the draft we couldn't see
other trades during the draft and i
still don't rule out the possibility of
the dolphins trading up to number one
and getting joe burrow just because the
bengals say they can't envision any
scenario where they would give up the
pick well that's just
exercising the leverage that may be
necessary to get the dolphins to give up
the maximum package and even though
brian flora is the coach of the dolphins
and chris greer the gm of the team
have reportedly resisted the concept of
giving up a lot to move up to number one
at the end of the day it comes down to
the owner and the owner loves joe burrow
and the owner is aggressive and if
steven ross sees
mid 70s late 70s this i think he's close
to 80 now this is the way to carry
through for the rest of his life a
quarterback who who provides them with
the franchise player they haven't had
since dan marino were retired more than
20 years ago
maybe steven ross says you know we've
pissed away plenty of draft picks over
the years what do we have to show for it
let's give them whatever they want let's
keep adding to the pile until we made
them an offer they can't refuse because
i want joe burrow to be the quarterback
of my team for the remainder of my life
and that can be a very powerful emphasis
when an owner starts to see that that
light at the end of the tunnel
and i'm trying to think of a delicate
way to put it but
you know
bottom line is
he's far closer to the end of the
beginning and if he realizes that he can
get through to the end with joe burrow
as his starting quarterback that may be
a way
to convince steven ross to trump his
head coach and his gm and get it done
speaking of getting it done i've got
some other things i have to do i'm i'm
uh
i'm gonna look and see for one more here
but i do have to get going uh
i'm looking for one more question here
scrolling scrolling i want to finish
with a good one come on somebody give me
a good one here i'll do the saul goodman
give me a good one here
here's one dirtbag 1327 is there any
doubt the patriots have some rubes on
the dark web hacking into everyone's
draft info they got nothing from their
latest sideline taping fiasco we still
don't know what's going to happen to the
new england patriots from that bengals
situation i should ask the league about
that that just kind of disappeared but
there was a belief they were going to
get punished and if they were going to
have draft picks taken away it would
have to happen fairly soon see another
reason why i like doing this it's
reminding me of something that i forgot
to look into i'm going to send the nfl
unless i forget between now and the time
i get back up to the house which is
entirely possible i'm going to ask the
nfl if there's been any update any
finalization of the
patriots bengal sideline taping fiasco
but i'll say this and i've said this
before and i think it bears repeating
anybody
who tries to cheat
during this draft
cheat by hacking into
whatever video conference software is
being used or just cheat in any other
way because this draft is driven by
one of the most unique situations we've
ever encountered the biggest public
health crisis in over a century
if anyone tries to use that to their
advantage
and they get caught
they should be punished like no team
coach owner gm whoever has been punished
before because it's one thing to cheat
in the normal course of business it's
another thing to exploit
an unprecedented crisis both physically
mentally
and financially i said both i came up
with three but it's affecting everyone
it's affecting us all in some way
to take advantage of this tragedy this
disaster is unfolding in slow motion
every day of our lives and god knows
where it's going to end if someone
cheats during a draft that was set up to
allow the process to go forward at this
time then they should get hammered by
the nfl like no one has been hammered
before all right that's it for a tuesday
edition of the pft pm podcast let's do
this again later in the week maybe on
friday or you know what if i feel like
it maybe we'll do it before then
everybody enjoy the rest of the day
tomorrow morning pft live big cat is
back
and we'll have our two hours live
two-hour re-air and stories and other
content for you around the clock at
profootballtalk.com
you